[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are
currently off the record here nothing
counts nothing counts yeah feel free to
say whatever you want slander people
that you hate can i just say luna is one
115 that's pretty crazy
oh should we do the stock market belt
yeah let's do it let's do it let's do it
gotta get high
we got a bunch of thousandaires and
millionaires in this room engineers dude
50 years hey don't don't brag
i made 25 because of luna thank you
there it is you got it games are games
oh that's possible did you like point
[ __ ] two lunars on this i feel kinda
[Applause]
thank you thank you daddy luna daddy
luna do we have
are we ready to talk about the other
coins in the hemisphere of crypto
outside of luna
and what we're excited about talk about
sheep and what our money's in
we could
here's the problem here's the problem
with that there's one that i'm
accumulating right now that i don't want
to talk about yet okay okay okay which
you guys know about actually okay it's a
secret yeah well uh there's stuff that
i'm kind of excited about but i'm gonna
keep it a secret too because also i
think i wanna be responsible enough to
where
if i am going to announce certain coins
i want to say it early enough so our
fans can get like a
chance at getting it but then i don't
i want to take the risk first
just in case because there's always a
risk right so it's like just in case
things might go sour
just because you get melted
i don't want them to be like you [ __ ]
me joel all you gotta do is say that
whole non-financial not financial
disclosure
and then be like i would buy all of this
but nfa giving advice
depending on the listener actually
because like us we don't care like we
just like we don't blame anyone if
anything happens right yeah but i think
like the regular person i blame steve
for making me broke the the listener is
so important because it's always it's
not always but a lot of times it could
be lose lose right it could be like like
let's say you like like what joe's
saying i want to test it first but then
like let's say it pumps if it pumps then
you tell them then they're like why did
you tell me sooner so you could make
money first right those are the people
that you don't want to talk to exactly
and then you try to shake them out
anyway
and then you go all right you know then
then i'll just tell you what i'm gonna
do it and then you tell me you're gonna
do it and it dumps a little bit and like
see
you know what though like steve's a good
guy because he literally just wants
everyone to win so he'll tell everybody
i'm the opposite
i
you want everybody to lose no i don't
think people are responsible enough to
invest
and then because you've
more like so many times people have been
like or like people i've heard stories
of people are being like what the [ __ ]
steve and they're getting mad at you
right yeah sure they didn't even lose
money but it's the natural fluctuation
of the market this happens in stocks
this happens in real estate if it
fluctuates if they were buying while
everything was down and while they were
frustrated they would be millionaires
right now that's the whole point but do
they expect investments to be like a
skyrocketing straight
you know that's what i'm saying but a
lot of people are like that because
um i think most people don't have the
heart capacity to handle that kind of
most people don't invest so they don't
understand what to expect when they get
in there but you're getting
people that are early adopters that's
never invested before and i'm just like
i never [ __ ] do that because it's
dangerous like they'll blame you for
everything well my people blame me for
uh for getting really [ __ ] rich
you're getting fast
well crypto corner is different they
want to do it right like somebody on
crypto corner was yelling uh at me i
think jokingly was like i've never
listened to a dance drink until you buy
luna at 99.
but today he's like up money so it's
like it's all [ __ ] it's all relative
and that's why the listener is so
important because the the average person
is this they'll be down to go
hey i'm gonna buy i'm gonna take a loan
out right to buy a car
and then literally drive it off the lot
it depreciates yes
that's the average person you're right
yeah then you go how about take half of
it and just put it in this it could go
up too your car is never going to go up
right true and then they're like
well depends because i sold my coffee
cup doing that one
i bought a used car that went on this
guy dude yeah but so it's like that's
the i think people have to get over that
thought or that mindset or that heart
capacity first before they can get in or
else it gets into a dangerous place but
we want everybody to think like that
because then the even playing field will
happen like we want us like wake up from
the matrix yeah we want our fans
we want our fans to to have that mindset
and then crush it but then all the other
[ __ ] like loser fans we want them to
[ __ ] yeah lose their faces
they keep watching but they're loser
fans
our fans are losers i'm talking about
like wong fu fans all other fans
that's true buzzfeed fans yeah
david soul fans are [ __ ] damn they're
not even here anymore people eating at
bobo mofo
i want come to jubilee food barbell
friends
dude they spend all their money on
protein anyways don't got money invest
yeah
dude
jk fans are the only ones to win yeah
but not the loser ones not the loser
fans not the david soul fans
especially the david so i miss david
yeah go [ __ ] watch david he's on
youtube
david so what
where are the girls go on [ __ ] big
moves what are we talking about yeah
other fans go out and get out of here
big nude was the first one you wanted to
talk about there
right there we're the girls pornhub
well yeah
that'd be nice there's two aspects to
crypto though where i'm like
um i i am i side with steve when it's
like trying to get everyone to adopt it
because i am a strong believer of
decentralized finance i don't like the
whole corrupted system of centralized
finance so that's in that
aspect i want to get as many people in
but the other aspect of investing right
like people
that have never done it before
i think they get hella greedy and they
look at it and then they see the success
of other people and they've never been
burnt before so then
i've
i i don't know i just don't want to be
the guy that's like oh you did this you
did and i'm like yeah just hold your
[ __ ] money and you'll be rich [ __ ]
but i don't want to listen to you
complain well know what you know what
you bought why you bought it right you
have to understand like like going into
it why are you putting money into it and
then if it dips that's exact that's why
it's an opportunity and not like oh i'm
[ __ ] folks i'm so [ __ ] yeah like
those guys all take owls right those
guys like literally sell to lost and
they're like i just went out of this
thing or they sell it break even it's
ridiculous
if they if they were just seeing the
dips as opportunities yeah they'd be in
the winner's circle with us but but
unfortunately not everyone can be is
just how it is you taught me that steve
green hey right now taught me how to to
read the dips and say oh time to buy and
now i'm up 25
he checked baby warren buffett the the
number one stock man in the whole entire
world who hates crypto his method is uh
value investing right so his whole
concept is you don't sit there trade and
try to like get rich off of gambling you
try to find the stock or the value of a
company
at an early stage you can see the
trajectory you see a solid team you have
faith in it and you go you know what
there's a lot of value here it's
undervalued such as maybe walmart in the
early ages or amazon in the early ages
if you can identify
seriously you're not wrong
by the sears dip
this is the second day we've talked
about sears this week you're not wrong
if you invested in sears in 1930 and
then you [ __ ] sold at 1916. no dude
i've been holding since 1930 bro
you got to be the wall street bets for
sears
but to that though in investing it's all
timing too you're a genius when you sell
when it's high and you're a genius when
you buy when it's low not the other way
around like anthony
it used to be it used to work so well
but now i'm luna 150
but that's the funny thing right is like
if you really believe in this [ __ ] and
if you know it's going to be the next
amazon you know you did your studying
you're like
right now let's say amazon at the time
was like 30 bucks or some [ __ ] and you
go man it's undervalued i know it's
gonna go to a thousand if you know this
then why the [ __ ] are you crying when it
dips like 20 bucks
which amazon did do right like a [ __ ]
tank [ __ ] hella hard after it's ipo
before it came back up yeah
and i mean i guess that's the whole
point of investing and i don't have the
heart to sit there and explain to him
i'm like hey man all this money you also
have to be responsible that if it goes
to zero that's on you don't [ __ ] play
with money you don't got mm-hmm yeah for
sure that's why i was able to [ __ ]
weather
almost a mil drop into 10 grand but i
knew that wasn't real money that's
[ __ ] crazy every time you say it
it was it was definitely real money but
yeah stomach
you got a stomachache
oh my well i did freak out because i
owed 250 000 in taxes that i didn't have
but basically
aside from that
when i look when are you going to write
the book you know
value investing by joe jutsu
geez
the best part though is that you did
weather the storm and you you had you
said so here's the thing right set a
plan right set a plan five year plan
five year plan so he already knew that
he already knew going in that he was
like he told me that when he was buying
ethereum and i was only year two he's
like steve i'm buying and i'm just gonna
hold it for five years and that's that's
my plan right so i've also seen john do
this with plans too though okay fair
and contracts
literally right after he's done he goes
i don't know
[Laughter]
today's video is brought to you by feels
cbd is not about what you feel it's
about what you do not feel such as
stress anxiety pain all of that mother
[ __ ] in your life okay me myself and
i i like caffeine especially vietnamese
coffee oh the vietnamese you know we got
energy drinks we got all kinds of stuff
that makes us go over and at the night
time i cannot relax but thanks to fields
i have this whole sleep regimen where i
put a couple of drops on my tongue and
then i just like to meditate relax
unwind and i knock the hell out yeah
what's awesome about them too is if
you're like oh i feel kind of
intimidated that's cool that's why they
have the hotline that can walk you
through because cbd is one of those
things where you want to find the exact
amount that's right for you so you can
call and you can check them out and
they'll walk you through so you feel
comfortable and the cool thing is
there's no hangover no addiction it's a
natural way to help you chill out you
know and i like to feel good so you
could become a member today by going to
feels.com
off the record to get fifty percent off
plus free shipping that's f e a l s
dot com slash off the record o f f t h e
r e c o r d to get fifty percent off
your first order plus free shipping
it's part of the five-year plan man yeah
yeah yeah so i'm just gonna rip up a
plan
why didn't i stick to the plan i'm gonna
quit five times in five years
it's called pivoting goddammit
knowing when to pivot by joe josekawa
featuring sears that's the second book
value investing and then pivot whatever
the [ __ ] you want
pictures him ripping the plane like this
your book should be how to make a mini
cooper appreciate it
and then and then it should have a
little side photo that says dealerships
hate him yeah and he's leaning on he's
leaning on the mini cooper like the book
cover right now i told you so book cover
the whole [ __ ] time dude the whole
run you know what the best part is we
beat everything you could google it go
find an investment that did better than
luna good luck on my coinbase it says
tara luna went up eight thousand percent
that's pretty crazy yes certainly i
don't even know i don't know anything
about that
that just sounds like a lot
i can't wait till we bring back money
masters
we're going to be wearing valencia
with the [ __ ] mic like this can't
wait dude we're going to fly in on a
private jet we're going to rent a
concert hall in vegas and we're gonna
have a i told you so [ __ ] marathon
it's gonna be great telethon
i told you so telethon
trust me you don't want to leave at
lunch because we're gonna be [ __ ]
hookers on stage
after the intermission dude that
but i like the look of it nick's
performing with the kid just yeah dude
it's gonna be my debut i can't wait just
[ __ ] judo slamming all of them nah to
the music
oh
[ __ ] dude don't show him yet dude hey
i'm not bad moving the shadows
there are people though right so so um
it's about you have to also set up
strategies for yourself so it's like i
have a plan i'm going to invest in this
for years like joe did right and then
there's also ways to win where it's like
i'm going to set up passive income
streams like using miners or whatever
and the reason why you do that
is is and i haven't you know you guys
know i've been helping people get into
crypto for a long time but some people
will go well i'm not going to stop this
minor what what i would do which would
be more beneficial to me anyway is i'll
just buy that coin every week and i'm
like you won't do it you won't [ __ ]
do it and if they did do it there was
this one coin called see a coin where
before it was even a cent i was like
guys we're gonna set up a seo coin miner
i bought all the [ __ ] [ __ ] i spent
like five g's on a mining rig and i was
like we're gonna plug it into my buddy's
house and let's just mine this [ __ ] the
whole [ __ ] bear market well
everybody's freaking out through the
bear market saying it's over and all
[ __ ] and so these guys didn't want to do
it anymore and i was like damn it we
have to like if if we were accumulating
this the whole time that'll be really
good when the bolt comes back and like
the ball is not going to magnify and
grip doesn't work and i'll sit and if
they were do if they were doing that
with me the entire time that would have
been a million dollar stack just right
there so that's the thing you have to
have the discipline and you have to know
what you don't have discipline about set
the plan for yourself so even if it's a
passive income stream you know that
you're not gonna sit there and buy it
every [ __ ] week but if you do have a
mining rig something you invested money
in and time in
and you keep that thing going then
you'll be working for yourself like as a
passive income stream but a lot of
people don't have the discipline to do
that but if you did do that
that's how you take that's how you get
the big wins too so i remember see a
coin because um i needed to pay some
taxes and i was like
oh damn thanks for this one steve and i
came up like 60 grand
and what did i do i sold it
no to the moon i'm not oh that's right
like a [ __ ] and i said no
this was my tax payment money yeah and
then you sold it under a penny
and then and that is an example of how i
didn't stick to the plan
but you learned from that
you're supposed to sell out a dollar uh
well i i said get a million of them and
then yeah right now they'd be 100 grand
yeah that's the thing i think i came up
like it was like 67 grand or something
and i didn't put that much in and then i
was like you know what
this would be a responsible thing like
i'm not like the coin wasn't a long-term
coin it was a quick trade for me so i'm
like
you know i could take profits here i
need to set aside money and be
responsible and you know i have to pay
taxes on this stuff and i said all in
baby
and then the [ __ ] crash happened
so i guess um
that was my lesson is i like to go a
thousand percent on everything with
nothing in my bank account right i was
impressed
so a thousand percent it's even never
been heard of because it's more than a
hundred but it's like actually the same
third of an eight thousand percent eight
thousand tara luna all right
i'm just saying dude that's pretty crazy
i've heard of a thousand though thousand
percent [ __ ] dude that's [ __ ] but then
thousand is luna dude
because my my i think there's also the
financial like investment strategy but
there's a life strategy and i'm always
thinking so far ahead that i forget
about where am i gonna get a burrito
tomorrow
and then so that's why you buy hella
burritos at once
you're investing in the week yeah you
see all those frozen he offered me a
burrito this morning yeah he did for me
too i pulled like four out of this bag
and put it in the freezer you want one
burritos when we walk in you're up in
burrito
i'm actually serious can we edit that
out because i'm trying to accumulate
frozen burritos right now and and i
don't want everyone to be buying that
you're gonna start a bear market for
burritos i specifically look for hotels
that have a breakfast bar so i can
accumulate burritos and i can bring the
burritos here that's good and have free
breakfast i have so many are you gonna
get the burritos here i'm gonna buy
plenty
no i [ __ ] buy a hotel
i i get a hotel room for 150 bucks and i
get one free burrito that's how i get
them
that's your racket that's my racket dude
complimentary burrito complimentary
burrito the best part about it actually
joe figured out that it's not illegal to
move burritos
yes it's fda approved actually it's a
lot but he's getting them from north
korea though
because they invented it he did defend
it oh yeah straight from the store so
i'm very pure so you guys look like
that's a hotel room you gotta you gotta
look for hotel rooms at free breakfast
all right that's true which ones have
three free uh frozen burritos yeah
that's very specific a lot of them best
western yeah thanks to the pandemic
because they don't have breakfast bars
they need to put on the sign instead of
colored tv yeah yeah we have hbo like
let me know 17 channels more like bean
and cheese burritos i haven't seen a
hotel with a black and white tv in a
long time i know it doesn't sound like
that's a good thing bart
he's like bumped it's good for everybody
it's right there it's they're all color
tvs now yeah that's true yeah why is
that a purple we have bathrooms a queen
sized bed
aren't they all queen size beds i like
when it says love spa i'm always like oh
what's a love spot
it's something that is
[Laughter]
it's like the love motels in korea yeah
what's a love motel in korea it's just
like there's different streets and stuff
like that that have like a bunch of uh
more affordable are all the light bulbs
red in that street or no no no no just
rent them to have sex they know you're
not gonna stay there for 12 hours so
it's cheaper oh like for hookers wow no
but okay but like you know that too you
can go with your woman
no it's because there's a lot of huge
drinking culture as well out there so
like a lot of people just get drunk they
need something to say that's not super
expensive that's one or they get drunk
they meet people they want to mm-hmm
that's pretty good you know oh so so so
biggest lesson learned right because the
biggest lesson learned is like yeah i
enjoy going a thousand percent but then
there's what i call the gray area which
is if you can figure out a way to create
passive income that will just pay for
your living expenses let's just say like
you calculate what your rent is your
phone bills how much you average spend
on your food and you don't stray away
from that let's say it's 5 000 bucks a
month figure out that situation and then
have a passive vehicle that just pays
that every month and that was my
solution to my turmoil
yup and as much as i want to find a way
to take that money that's in my passive
account and blow it all on other [ __ ]
coins and whatever i gotta tell myself
do not do that but that was like my
journey like you know when i went
through that four years ago and i was
like all right and that's why i have
super homeless habits like going
to collect every single breakfast bag
that i can at every hotel
and i can hoard it here in the jk office
so i can eat breakfast for free you guys
notice i don't even order starbucks
because i have breakfast burritos
even though the company's paying for the
starbucks i [ __ ] feed you guys first
so i could get a free burrito at a
breakfast bar but isn't the company
paying for the burritos
the 150 dollar burrito
so your loophole goes in the loop
basically i don't know that's out of
pocket dude
get it my bad dude my bad i suppose that
my bad dude all hail joe jacob
our fearless leader